réutiliser réduire recycler voici les
maîtres mots du centre de recyclage a
bold as dix mille tonnes de déchets ils
sont traités chaque année ce qui
représente 300 kg de déchets par
habitant
nous avons des accords avec d'autres
entreprises qui viennent collecter les
motos et qui les collectent et enfin de
nouveaux matériaux qu'ils nous payent
pour avoir collecté tous ces matériaux
et cet argent retourne elle aussi cela
réduit la facture des gens donc plus il
ya de gens qui trichent et qui le font
de manière correcte moins ils auront à
payer
après le centre de recyclage les
participants du projet gira découvre
l'une des sept réserves de biosphère
suédoise la vallée de la vox nan
preserved l'unique nous avons un projet
ici ou nous voulons préserver la flore
uniques que nous trouvons sur la piste
de ce symbole à nice tu es venu et a
recensé plus de 100 espèces différentes
beaucoup d'entre elles explique leur
présence grâce aux paysages qui est
régulièrement de son dû
préservation de la nature développement
des énergies éoliennes circuits courts
le meeting suédois a permis de passer en
revue de nombreuses thématiques et
solutions liées aux problématiques des
zones rurales a été extrêmement bien
reçue
et surtout que les suédois rouis la
volonté de nous montrer des initiatives
positives
des façon de motiver les gens à
travailler en faveur du développement
durable plutôt qu'à chercher
systématiquement à les punir quand ils
trient pas leurs déchets ou qui font pas
les choses correctement les six
délégations se sont d'ores et déjà donné
rendez vous à la mi septembre pour la
quatrième étape du projet qu'ils laura
aux pays bas objectif regrouper dans un
manuel les bonnes pratiques européennes
[Musique]